S
N
.ONAL PARIAHEA OFFIC
READMRIA ASITMEARSIVHUE
F ULRN
IGHT ON THE
AT
WEEK.
NDLENOW
A REALITY.
GUE HAS REINSTATEDSY THACADE OVE
PRSAAD ACICLAR OF ANLED TO
POL PROT T
ON FOR
ARS.
>> WLKING NOW AHE
AVE A LEADING ROLE
WILL ALLIT WILL COME TO
THE ANNOUNCEMENTIT
ICIPATE IN
ACTIEN
G A  OFCOME SYRIAN' A SIS
DIPLOMATIC AS PRESIDSE IAS
R A RUYEARS.
TYR'S
BE
--ER OF IGIR HISTINUESNHEREGIMEW
SERIOUS ASCEND
ATTARGETS INSIDE SYRIAO TG A FOD
PARTOXFOF SYRIANFUY ACIDS
WAIT MAYHADECISION APORTRAYAL.
TH IS OOK HIMSE WE A
BACK.
ALL ULEINSTEAD OF IS
ICIPATINUS IN GETTING USUT WHERS
THE T
CD TO
N OF SYRIA IS BEGI
O THISRIRIA.
>>HIANGINGEN
NDSCAP TEACAITN UNCERTAI W
THE CRITICISM ITLFOT DOING
GH OTIES WH BASHARL-OUPEN
LETTACRGING
SPECAN I
AMBASSADORJOININUSME SABSOLU SYN
PEOPLE.
SADS TO TEG GN HERE AND WHYELTWD
IS IPP>>HSS, I WOULD EMPHASIZTOE
G OF ACEIT'S VERY THIS IS BOTH ,
IT'S MORE.
SINCE THE  OBAMA
ADMINISTRATIITH JOHN K
THROUGP
STRATION,, THE U.S.
TED NEGOTIATIONSWHAT
THE ARAB LEAE TO DTHAT IS TO OFH
PROBLEMS TWE IN YOUR REPORT.
THE IRANIADA
L ISTHE VARIOUS TERRORIST GR
H IN SE
THERETHE PROBLEM WITH REFUGEESO
RE NOTNAFIXED BY ASSAD BEING INE
ARAB LEAGUE.
THA  TD EUROPEAN SANCTIONS.E NOH
D U.S. TROOUSR
OUOFSP REQUIRES THE SOD TO MESE
DE THAR.
TONYLITHE SECRETARY OF
D THE FON THURSDAY.
HE'S THEDEHIS  ME S TO BE
DONE T SCORDANCE WITH THE LUTIOF
LEMS.
WE HAVTOS A IT DOES OW THAT THEB
WHWH LETTEOUOPNU AREIN
WO E OIOSHR THERE.
>>E WERE ALL AWARE OF EABKING ON
A YEF O.HE DELIVERED A VERSIONIO
'RE CONE WRONGROT THABILITY TO I
OUT.
SAISAS
AS SHOWN HLL
FEF COOF ARAB LEADERGST THEMES
AD TO COMPLY,S
AN PVIIODOLLARS A YEAR.E IS NOTH
OR THE TERRORIST GROUPS OF THE
TING THAT'S STILG IA.
THIS IS A GEOPOLALITNVOLVEPOIG N
FOR ARAN SE
REGION.
WANT THAT.
EY WANT TO GET IRAN OUT AND
THEY WANT -RTULIA CALM.
M NOT  OE BEST A
--
IGGER ROLE.
EAD, WE'RE GOING TO LET THE WITS
R MA>>HATHDORERE THE PITFALLS OD
E ANFOOTHOLDS STILTH LAT
EE>> SURE, YOUEEASSAD WAB D ARAF
UDR
OTHERS ARE GONNA OR
FOR THE400 MILLION
DESTRUCTIONE RUSSIANS THE
ANLFASDE SYRIA.
AMERICAN ISRAELI MILITARY OPETIO
HE STILL ONER NONE OF THOSE
TO4'RESOLUTION.EUET THISEI FABON
ASSAD ONY MUCH.
PROGRESS.ETH ARAB LEAGUEAV
TIHOW RTANT IS ITHOSETO TRYASAAE
GRATION HERE.
OU THAT IS HAPPENI
XC.
T YOUR FINGEOBLEM.
IC ---YETESOLUTTOATIONAL PROBWIS
BUT ANCEON ITS
PROCESE PROCESS RATHER
FOCUS.TS YOU WANT  THEROCOME THE
THAT'S WHAT I'M AFF.
YRIANT EVEN
ON'TEN ACCEPTED.
WIP
THARE NOW
TABLE, WE'L HPY
COMP.TECI'M NOT SUREBELITARYVEHL
WE APPRECIATE ITFOVING ME.SSURKT
IS ACCORDING TANFERC INT
INTELLIGEN.THEY U
ATEARTHQUAKE